so i'm gonna do some tidying up and
i'm gonna do two things for starters
let's just get this one million out the
front here
uh it's always hanging out there
okay like so and then the two things i'm
going to change are to do with this
series of terms okay the first one is um
minus science gross i hate minus signs
they're really awful okay so what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna factorize out
a minus sign out of the whole thing okay
so all of these minuses
they're going to become pluses because
i'm going to factorize out all those
minus signs is that okay
i mean you could have left them there
but it's just the less minus signs there
are the better for me i'd rather have
one
covering all of these guys than all of
them together okay
good question this here is not a 10
it's a n in some ways i'm kind of
cheating because i'm looking to the next
question there's another question that i
have to work out right and i think
that question is gonna use this a lot
more easily if that makes it you'll see
when we do it together
okay all right so i've taken the minus
sign out there's one other thing i'm
gonna do
see how this um this series right it
goes like three two one
or like ten nine eight or whatever right
we tend to think more
intuitively in the other direction right
like one two three
uh and then you end wherever you want
i'm gonna do that over here so i've
taken out a minus sign
and i'm also reversing the order of the
series is that okay
so what are we going to end up with
if i'm reversing this the first term
will be
what the last term was what was the last
term before
is is 75 000 times 1.04 is that okay
now some of you are probably wondering
why didn't i factor out the 75 000 also
you will see why in a second okay what's
the next term
plus because i factorized out all the
minus signs
i'm counting from here now right so
instead of counting down
i'm now counting up so the next one
should be 75 000
times 1.04 and then i go up one right
so it'll be squared is that okay um i'll
do one for more for good measure
because i'm so good at counting one two
three that i'll just write down a three
what will the very last term be it'll be
n because that was my first term before
okay dot dot dot there should be a plus
sign there sorry that's a bit cheeky
sorry about that okay
now i'm ready i can say see this guy
here not that first term
it's separate you see how separate it is
i'm trying to highlight it's its own
thing right
but all these guys they're a gp
yeah so i'm going to say over here on
the right hand side and pull out another
color
if um if it helps you right i'm going to
say this
is a geometry progression
with i need to identify three things
three things will define every geometric
progression and they're there in the
formula
for a gp where do we start
literally where do we start the first
term right what's the first term
it's that one there right because
remember even though a million is the
first thing i wrote down
it's not part of the gp do you see that
right it's kind of just
sitting out there on its own like a
weird anti-social person so a
actually starts up in here it's okay so
i'm gonna write that down
what's the ratio
from one term to the next i'm
multiplying by 1.04
now normally at this point i would say
um n equals to tell you how many terms
there are but i don't really want to
write
n equals n because that seems a bit
strange and superfluous so instead i'm
just going to say n
terms because this is a gp with this a
this r and it's got n terms is that all
right
you're like oh what a beast of a line
look at this it takes like four lines to
write it okay i know it took some work
to establish that pattern
but now i can actually go and reach for
the formula i'm ready to use the formula
now
a of n will equal one million
times this guy it's not part of the gp
so it just hangs out there
okay minus
can we do the formula for a gp can you
help me assemble everything together
what's the first thing i write down
it's it's the a right that's what's on
the top of the that's on the numerator
of this formula so it's
75 000 times 1.04
like so so there's my a and then there's
stuff in the brackets of this numerator
right what's in the brackets
yeah it's hold on hold on careful you've
got the formula there right it's
r to the n minus one right so in this
case it's
1.04 to the n
minus 1. is that okay and then i divide
by
r minus 1. there's r to the n minus 1
and then there's
r minus one on the bottom okay
now those of you who are asking before
uh why didn't i factorize out the 75 000
here
i mean i could have but the reason i
didn't is because it just comes back
here
like it's factorized out anyway okay all
right now
on the approach for a minute you guys
now can take that go to your calculator
what's the particular a we're looking
for which one
a 10. so wherever you see n
go ahead to your calculator and put in a
10. be careful with your input because i
know it's um
it's a bit of a tricky mess to put in
there but go ahead and do that
and then we'll get a number out of it
[Music]
yep
have a think about this whole situation
right you're getting paid money
where did that money come from it came
from how much you saved
right so it's there and it keeps on
getting interest because you don't take
all of it out immediately
correct because you're not finding this
i will once i've done all my
subtractions as well so this is all my
withdrawals
and this is my original amount that i
saved the amount
you just used this is the amount we've
drawn here
okay question or answer
go ahead
oh yeah okay we're not there yet have
you got a already is that what you're
saying
can you give us a 10 can anyone give us
a 10
go ahead parent uh 543 767
okay do we have some agreement thank you
aaron who's got that number
happy no eddie no yes okay great okay i
was like
no i disagree just to be contrary all
right now uh quick sense check
says check does that make sense 10 years
pulling 75 000 every time if there was
no interest if there was no interest
and you pulled 75 000 out of here every
year for 10 years
how much would you have withdrawn
10 lots of 75 000 right 750
000 so you would have had a quarter of a
million dollars at the end 250
000. this is a lot more than that why is
it so much more
it's the it's the interest right and you
started with this huge
what's sometimes called a nest egg right
it's massive four percent of this
four percent of this it's forty thousand
dollars right
can i say that again four percent of
your million is
did i calculate it right i did right
forty thousand dollars so even though
you're pulling out 75
40 000 gets re-accrued if that makes
sense roughly anyway
okay eddie's checking my numbers okay
all right